[Music]
hey everybody
it's monday hey are you joining us
he's like looking at his tablet he's not
even paying attention i'm like are you
ready to turn the camera on or what
uh yeah somebody was just saying in the
comments that ronnie defeo had died
i was like i didn't even realize that he
was still alive to be honest with you i
thought he died a long time ago
well i guess i was thinking about the
lutz's because they died a long time ago
so i don't know why i would confuse
those two people i guess because it's
all amityville
because you know but i i didn't even
realize that ronnie defeat was still
alive
um he was in prison presumably
i guess trying to get back to the stream
got knocked out of it okay
okay uh how's it going
well it's going pretty good today uh you
know we're just
talking about this new shutter original
which they just added
yeah the shutter originals turned out to
be pretty good a lot of times they they
seem to spend their money
pretty well on these yeah some are
pretty decent this was no exception it's
a pretty good little flick
um kinda in kinda in the uh
in the spirit of traditional 80s and 90s
horror flicks
some about this kind of reminded me a
little bit of crawl space
oh yes wait there were yeah yeah yeah
because i was going to say the klaus
kinski one is the one i remember i think
there's another movie called crawl space
that i don't think i've seen
but i've seen the klaus kenski one turns
out they find joseph mangala
well it's like it's not a big deal okay
so uh so this is uh stay out of the
[ __ ] attic
uh i think the card on shutter just says
stay out of the attic but it's actually
called stay out of the [ __ ] attic
so uh the premise of the movie
is that you have this moving company uh
the second chance moving company
and it's comprised of i guess it was
started by a dude who was an ex-con
and his thing is that he always like
hires ex-cons to
work at his company because he thinks
they deserve obviously a second chance
so they get this job to clean out this
really quite creepy looking sort of
victorian-ish looking mansion
and they go in there and like the dude
gives him like a ridiculous amount of
money but he's like look um
i need all of this [ __ ] out of the house
like by
tomorrow morning even though it's a
massive house and there's a bunch of
[ __ ] in there
and he's like look i'll give you like
four times your normal rate like
an extra thousand dollars and all this
other kind of stuff and since these
people are obviously
need the money they're just like okay
well we'll try to do it here's one thing
i always kind of wondered about though
you know i've i've never utilized a
moving company obviously you know i'm
always broke so i always got to move my
own self
but um so when a move bring when a
moving company comes to your house
do they not expect you to already have
most of your ship packed up
no i would imagine really some of them
they'll buy they'll pull out boxes and
start throwing in boxes and pack the
whole thing for you
some of those companies holy [ __ ] i
didn't know that yeah i mean i thought i
knew they'd move like your furniture and
whatnot but i thought you know like all
your little books and knickknacks and
[ __ ] i was like
i would have thought you you would have
at least had to put everything in boxes
for the people
no i mean but some some would some
services would like some people if you
were wise you'd probably do that
you'd want other people going through
your [ __ ] well that's what i'm saying no
they got copies that'll sit there and
[ __ ] just pack everything just pack
all
which is what they do in this one
because it just seems like
because i don't know like the movers
walk in and i'm like dude he hasn't even
put anything in boxes what the [ __ ]
that's rude
but uh yeah so like they they don't seem
you know
out of sorts by it or anything there's
like okay we got all the bubble wrap and
[ __ ]
so uh as the title of the movie implies
this creepy old
german man you know red flag right there
creepy old german man
tells them yeah we need all this uh
stuff out of here by the morning but he
specifically tells them not only to stay
out of the attic also to stay out of the
basement
but i was reading this one review of it
they said
and they said even though they're not
supposed to go down in the basement
either probably the title of it
shouldn't you know
wouldn't be as good if it was stay out
of the [ __ ] attic and also the
basement
but uh that's pretty much the premise of
the movie though so um
because this is a horror movie uh they
can't just leave it alone
they start packing up the [ __ ] even
though they're taking forever even
though they're supposed to
do it by the morning and they i think
they
they originally like start kind of
poking around because they get a bad
feeling or whatever but then they start
hearing weird [ __ ] like upstairs like
somebody yelling or
yelling for help or something so
obviously they do end up going in the
[ __ ] attic and they find a girl in
there
that has her twin sister sewn to her
back
right yeah the twin sisters kind of
deformed
and uh as it turned out like i said it's
kind of a spoiler i guess but not really
because
you know the this isn't like some big
you know big
reveal or big twist or anything it turns
out that the
creepy german man that owns the house is
actually joseph mengele
and he has developed some kind of serum
i guess
uh for prolonging his life
yeah obviously because he would yeah 100
something if he'd be really dead by now
uh by basically i don't know if i want
to spoil like what
the serum is made of but i will say you
know what
whoever wrote this movie it was directed
by jaren
lawdert i guess i'm pronouncing that
right or law dare if you want to be
french about it
but um i think it had like four three or
four different writers including him
and whoever this was um
obviously this isn't an overtly
fulchy-esque movie
but there's a couple moments in there
where i was like i see what you did
there you know what i mean because
there's one like eye
trauma scene that kind of reminded me of
the zombie thing
and then just kind of a little bit of
the vibe of it gives me a house by the
cemetery dr freudstein
type of [ __ ] you know what i mean so
obviously
somebody that uh that was behind this
was kind of like making little homages
to
lucio folgi in there i saw that i saw it
um
it's not like i said it's not a
fantastic movie but it's like a pretty
enjoyable movie um
you know the the characters are likable
acting isn't
great but it's you know workmanlike it's
above average
yeah it's it's kind of it's it's fun
yeah uh it's got some gore in it
a couple we would have ran we would have
rented to this case yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean of course you're gonna of
course you're gonna run a movie called
stay out of the [ __ ] attic yeah
even even in this day and age if you
have uh you know a horror movie with a
title like that
i'm gonna want to see it i mean i still
want to see the horror movie that's
called run [ __ ] run
i haven't watched it yet but every time
i say i think it's on tubey
it's like every time i walk through i'm
like man i need to watch that you can
put that title on about
on most of most horrors well any horror
movie like
any slasher movie anyway and uh is it
i think there's one too called you don't
[ __ ] with stephen king or
you don't [ __ ] kill stephen k or
something like that i don't remember
something like that so i probably end up
watching that one too
but i do feel like it's kind of that's a
good way to kind of get you push your
movie into
public consciousness is still by putting
like a [ __ ] swear word in the title
but yeah you know like i said it's not a
fantastic but it's not a waste of time
either
also um shutter they're doing the new
season of creep show is starting
in april sometime so next month i don't
know if it's the beginning of the month
or the middle of the month i can't
remember now
but they are doing what is it season
three i don't know i guess it's season
three or season two i don't remember i
guess it's season creep show oh
good thing with season three i think i
think it's season three as well
because remember they did like those
kind of specials like those one-off they
did like the christmas one and then they
did like the animated one yeah
but you know uh yeah so i feel like
i don't know i feel like shutters added
a bunch of stuff lately and i haven't
gotten around to watching
a lot of because i used to be real good
about keeping up with all the new [ __ ]
that they
added but they've added a bunch of like
old movies too and i even haven't got
around to watching those
some of them i've seen already but you
know what it
what what oh
you look like you look like you're going
to say something just like sleeping
are you kind of sleeping how can you be
sleepy that's how it is man
you're always sleepy that's how it is
it's all that and now it's all that
testosterone
man that's all that [ __ ] liquid
healing
just makes you feel good you know well i
mean it's not much good healing if all
you're going to do is sleep
i had a lot of catching up to do i guess
we got to go out tonight yeah that's
right we actually
yeah we didn't go out saturday night
because we're going to go out tonight
because it's memento mori
because what ended up happening was that
they had a memento mori last month
they don't know what that is it's uh
well i've mentioned it before
it's the goth industrial night you're
right at independent bar downtown
orlando
um they had one last month but i totally
spaced on what day it was and
i thought i thought it was the following
monday so then like tuesday
my friend goes was like where were you
guys last night and i was like what are
you talking about i was like oh [ __ ]
well
i forgot what day it was that's what
happened but yeah
so do you have anything else you'd like
to add about stay out of the [ __ ]
attic
no um you know like i said it's worth
watching don't don't
like go out of your way to watch it or
anything but if you like kind of movies
about
nazi doctors and it is what it is people
yeah
it's just kind of like a fun throwaway
yeah kind of you know i've certainly
seen better ones on there but i've seen
like some marshall on stage but as good
as blood pass
no i really liked blood vessels well
just because like i said that was a
vampire movie but they were coming at it
from like
an angle you don't really see all that
much which i thought was kind of cool
um but yeah and so probably tomorrow
uh we're gonna do the wolf of snow
hollow because i watched that last night
and i liked that a lot so i'm gonna talk
about that tomorrow as well
but uh yeah so i guess something's been
kind of short but we have to do
we have to record a movie review too
uh and we haven't done it yet oh uh
xanada
if you are here or if you watch this
later
we sent you a pliskin shirt today that
got mailed out that got mailed out so
keep on the lookout for that uh should
only be a couple of days probably
but yeah we will uh be back tomorrow
hopefully not too hungover
talking about another horror movie and
uh like i said sorry this is kind of
short
but we will see you tomorrow bye